en el décimo día de protestas masivas
continuaron los enfrentamientos
violentos entre la fuerza pública y los
manifestantes en ecuador que dejaron dos
comuneros fallecidos uno de ellos al
recibir un impacto de un cilindro de gas
lacrimógeno en la cabeza con el
estancamiento de los diálogos no se
vislumbra un final para las
movilizaciones sociales
tierno nacional de brecon
manos ya tiene manchadas de sangre lo
que pasó en guayllabamba en lo que pasó
en pastaza no puede trasladar esta
responsabilidad a nuestros dirigentes la
conaie la organización indígena
organizadora del paro nacional emitió un
pliego de 10 pedidos y condiciones para
sentarse a negociar con el ejecutivo de
guillermo lasso como el cese de la
represión la derogación del estado de
excepción o el respeto a las zonas de
resguardo humanitario por su parte desde
el gobierno ecuatoriano alegaron estar
dispuestos a dialogar pero rechazan las
condiciones de la organización el
diálogo sincero no admite condiciones
señor hizo tenemos urgentes problemas
nacionales que resolver y la violencia
no es la forma sino las protestas se
iniciaron el 14 de junio para exigir que
se reduzca el precio de la gasolina de
los productos agrícolas y una mayor
inversión estatal para la educación y
pese a iniciar de forma pacífica se han
ido intensificando con los días y la
represión policial